جنوب شرق تركيا وتحديدا مجمع النهضه
السكني الفاخر او ما تبقى منهم بعد
الزلزال هناك كانت الحياه احلام وهموم
وتفاصيل عديده اما الان لم يتبقى سوى
انقاذ والبومات
بعد شهر من الزلزال او على بعد شهرين من
الانتخابات الاستحقاق المصيريه التاريخيه
في تركيا
كمال كليجدار اوغلو زعيم حزبي الشعب
الجمهوري مرشح التحالف
المعارضه المشترك للانتخابات الرئاسيه هذا
التوافق وصف بالخطوه التاريخيه المرشح
المنافس الجمهوريه قدمه زعيم حزب السعاده
الاسلاميه كتفا بكتف من مع رفاق السابقين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في الاعلانيه ايضا ظهرت
رئيسه حزب الجيد ضد الطاوله اسداسيه الذي
كاد ان يفكك تحالف المعارضه لكن هل عوده
اكشنار الرقبه الصدعه داخل تحالف المعارضه
ربما وربما عمقها لكن لا التحالف ولا
اكشنر يمكنهما ان يتراجع خطوه لماذا
الكلفه السياسيه عاليه قد تقضي على
مستقبلها السياسي وقد تهدم تهدي الخصم
اللدود الرئيس اردوغان وحزبه الح ما يريده
تفتيت جبهه المعارضه
[موسيقى]
جدا